I'm welcoming Triple H into the room
that he owns and has invited me in yeah
this is weird to see a man in that room
there's such a difference what a man
what a what a man is and then what what
you are Sam M Bob Kelly's there in New
York with him and they were just
pointing out that after watching me all
morning it's really odd to see a man
walk in if you said can I just say
something Sam if you said Shazam that's
[Laughter]
you know think so so they're concerned
Bob Kelly especially turns down because
you're screaming at me yeah I like that
he's told Sam Sam you're too loud
they're saying that because my hair is
trimmed down from where it used to be
right that I don't provide enough
pizzazz yeah no peak or NXT anymore yeah
he's flat that's the word I was looking
for
he's as flat as my sister no I went to a
stylist to get this done you know a
curly hair specialist I want to ask you
Triple H because Sam is is too shy to
ask but he's been fairly adamant about
deserving to fly on the private plane
that's how he should be shuttled to and
from gigs and we would like to know if
there's any chance of that happening I
feel there's a possibility of that
happening but all these things have to
happen in steps like right now his
travel perks are Greyhound bus but we'll
get them to the bag lunch on the ground
move up the line eventually that's what
I like I like something with a lot of
potential lots of room to grow if you
apply yourself like you have yeah most
of your life that's it that's what Sam's
wife does to room for improvement yeah
so that plane how long were you with the
company because I know like flying on
the plane is the big thing did you start
immediately or did you kind of have to
be there for a couple of years before
you finally started getting on that no
you know it
funny people make a huge deal out of
that plane it is realistically the only
way that we can do that from a
television production standpoint is
pretty much the only way that we can do
what we do and get the places we need to
go to so when I was a talent I never
flew on that or anything else you know
from from a company standpoint from the
executives or from Vince's standpoint to
be able to get where he needs to be and
get back or whatever that is it is not
people oh it must be so nice you sit on
there and you eat sushi or whatever yeah
while you're working it's a working it's
an office in the air and and if
anybody's ever met Vince he doesn't stop
he's 24/7 so it's an office in the air
it's Vince okay if people go like oh you
know we just had a long night I'm gonna
take a nap before I doesn't happen yeah
you see a lot of people watching him if
he was to nod off you see a lot of
people he's on the go all the time and
that's really what that place is is a
flying off do you upgrade it every year
like is it is it the same plane for the
last you know 10 years the companies
have the same plane now for a while you
know I don't remember when they when
they got the new one but it's they've
had this one for a while and I like
being it do you like being a boss yes of
people like to go from I mean obviously
you relate to them in a different way
because not anybody not you for example
yes in the example of if you were
telling me what to do right now yeah but
now but when you're a boss like people
come up to you like you're the person
they go to they want things you get to
deliver the good news but you also
unless you hire somebody to deliver the
bad news for you
so one I don't necessarily look try to
look at myself as anybody's boss I try
to look at myself in the role of this is
a business where everybody has to work
together to get common stuff done that's
how I see it so it's a giant team the
point is though at some point I'm
somebody has to make the final decision
on things so you debate a lot of things
you talk about a lot of
and then somebody has to make the final
decision whether popular or unpopular
you have to make the final decision and
it's got to be solid and stick to it the
truth is nobody really understands that
role until they have that role you can
think when you're in the number-two spot
well this is so obvious I would do this
but when the pressure is on you to have
that decision being yours and live or
die by it right or whatever that's a
different it the dynamic absolutely
changes in the moment it becomes your
responsibility and then to not
second-guess and do all those things
it's it's a just the difference of even
just one show where you're in the
position of going along with things or
presenting your ideas and thinking like
this system we should do this it's so be
so much better or whatever but then when
that becomes your decision to make it's
a different here you have moments where
you've gone like this was my decision
and it didn't work and you're like oh Sh
absolutely yeah yeah absolutely anybody
that's in that position yeah absolutely
the truth is you don't know if the other
one would have worked better right a lot
of times you know there's a you'll hear
said in this business a lot sometimes
things are chocolate and vanilla right
so it's it's all ice cream it's all
pretty good but you want vanilla you eat
the chocolate you go like yeah that
wasn't really what I wanted today right
I don't know the vanilla might not have
been any better find that everybody
wanted strawberry anyway are you good at
making decisions people things that you
know they're not gonna like like some
guys who are bosses are comfortable
doing that I'm terrible at it like I
hate telling people things that I know
they're not gonna like are you
comfortable doing that I think so
because I think if if as long as you
have logical and reasonable explanation
now somebody might totally disagree with
you but if I as long as I feel like I
can defend my position of here's here's
what I'm telling you and here's why I'm
telling it to you like this is what I
feel should have happened whatever that
is whatever the reason is but as long as
you have that logical reason behind you
somebody might say well I disagree with
the outcome or whatever but okay but
here's how I got there it's not like I
just made this stuff up and decided I
don't like you so I'm gonna do this
right you know there's a logical reason
and as long as you're there yeah then
then you just have to you get make your
decision stick by but you have but the
problem is is that it's not like you're
at a subway where you're telling a 40
year old nerd the guys you're you're you
might have a problem an argument with
are huge like these are these are really
big guys I mean if you ever had a look
at we got to do this and they get so
pissed where it gets Bob you've met
Triple H he's also got some sides to him
well I'm looking at him I'm looking at
him next to you so I really actually a
maker now really close to the camera and
me for our business is a very
professional so you see the craziness
that you see on camera and on screen and
everything but behind the scenes
obviously there's a lot of emotion to
anything you do and you know passion of
what we do and all that stuff but for
the most part it everybody's pretty
professional and you're just having
discussions about things and sometimes
you got to tell somebody something they
don't like other times you give them
news they love so it it it it depends on
the day but everybody's reasonable do
you like it crossover you sorry do you
like the crossover you guys have had
with UFC it's really interesting between
a Brock and and Ronda two of the biggest
stars in both have kind of worked well I
mean Ronda went from one to the other
and Brock has kind of gone back and
forth you must be happy about that and
Shayna Baszler to who was on The
Ultimate Fighter Matt riddle is now all
right Matt real that's right yeah baby
riddle was an incredible yeah you know
standout UFC performer and then you know
made the transition what we do I am a
big believer in the athletes you know no
different than you see talent like a
Baron Corbin who you know I know he gets
a lot of heat but it's a phenomenal
performer it was an NFL player you know
came into this a little bit later was a
fan but then came into this a little bit
later as a performer you see braun
strowman coming in from strongman
competitions and so you see athletes
coming in from a lot of different
backgrounds but i think that's one of
the things that the that was the goal of
the performance center and when we did
this you know five or seven years ago
whatever
when we started terrible with dates but
when we the concept of this was to
create a pathway for people I would meet
people all the time in various either
sporting you know events or
entertainment that would just say man
I've always dreamed about doing that
I've been such a fan I would love to do
that
I just how do you get into it and there
was no there was no clear path to do
this you know I meet guys that were in
the NFL and think like I got another
year left but yeah I'm 23 right
something and a man I want I want to
continue to be an athlete and my I've
always dreamed of two things NFL I've
done that and in WWE and how can I get
there and to create that pathway for
them to create a place they could go
train just like you said they were at a
d1 college or a pro team so that they
can make that transition I think that
transition would be you know I don't
know that you would have seen a Ronda
make that transition or people like that
make the transition as successfully
without that that system how is how is
women's wrestling I mean it was you know
it's become huge and it's like back in
the day it wasn't as big as it was it
was always the guys but with women like
you know all the women like I just saw
that movie fighting with my family like
it's it's it's it's as big as the guys
now and as interesting for a wrestling
fan I love to watch those matches to
like was that something you guys did oh
is that something that just happened
what no it's something that we
consciously went after but also you know
you can say it's like the chicken or the
egg thing right look what our what our
fans and what is the world willing to
accept I think if you go back 20 years
ago and you say they're gonna be you
know with Dana White said at one point
I'm right there will never be women's a
may well the UFC will never have women
in and then along comes Ronda Rousey and
she captivates everybody um you know
there's a there was a period of time if
you go back 25 years 30 years ago that
anybody would think that oh the women's
soccer team would be bigger than the
men's soccer team in the US or that you
know the the world would be captivated
by the female gymnast or women's tennis
would be bigger than men's you know what
that stuff goes to
transitions and what people are willing
to accept but as you're kind of watching
what's happening in the world and seeing
what's going on and changing how they
are used to always even for me as a
talent I used to always think to myself
like man some of these women are really
talented but we don't allow them to to
do what they do and I don't know that
fans would accept it but like some of
them could be really skilled they've
just never been trained right so when
when I kind of came in and took over
developmental it was kind of blank
slating it and saying we're gonna
recruit different women we're gonna
recruit athletes we're gonna train them
the same way remember walking in here
one day and saying well they're not
allowed to do that they're trained like
this and I was like why right you know I
mean nobody could give me a good answer
so I was like all right so all that
stuff goes out the window now here's
what we're doing and we changed it and
when you started to give them those
opportunities and you had athletes like
Sasha
Becky Charlotte you know Amber moon and
and just Naomi at that time and and all
these women that were in the system that
just took that ball and ran with it and
you could very quickly see like oh my
god when they are applying themselves to
this and learning it in the same way
very quickly they were almost more
driven than the guys to prove a point
and they're they're knocking out of the
park you go no further than our fans
then with the give divas a chance
hash tag trying to globally for three
days and you know they drove that
process but we were already there with
it NXT started to give them a little bit
of a platform to people see it for
people to see it the fans got on to it
said this is what we want they demanded
it we followed suit and you know you
have to look no further than this year's
WrestleMania with Ronda Becky and
Charlotte and I mean yeah and not
because there was a moment in time where
we said oh let's make him the main event
and capture some headlines it had
nothing to do with it because they were
the main event you can clearly look at
that run into mania and go what was the
the most talked-about thing it was that
match what was the most talked-about
storyline that match what was the the
biggest attraction that match yeah there
was the match the fans wanted to see the
most - yeah everybody thought that
that's where it should be yeah yeah are
you and are you involved in the
production of like now you guys are
doing movies and tee
you involved in all that too or you just
in the wrestling side of it the live
events and the chosen more the wrestling
side of it alive events clearly I have
you know knowledge about what's
happening and you know all of the all of
the pieces and components and going
through from a bigger scope of what WWE
is you know I often say that WWE in the
you know people ask me where is it in 10
years or 15 20 years from now and and to
me I feel like we're that tipping point
where Debra Debra is little like a
disney or a marvel where it becomes less
about the comic books less about the the
princesses and the cartoon characters
and all of a sudden becomes this this
different entity that that all these
things movies television all these
different things roll into because at
the end of the day while what we do as a
core product is in ring we're really a
giant media company that is that is out
there promoting and and and doing all
this other media stuff and and that's
where we really excelled and that and
that's why sam has to get pizzazz he has
to show his hair back get a silver tie
something I mean look at his beard and
look at your beard that beard has levels
I mean the mustache is separated from
the beard I mean it looks great and then
your beard is just like you're like
you're a fisherman like you're in Canada
fishing for trout
there's fishermen who like wrestling too
though yeah absolutely but I bet they'd
want to relate there are I believe there
is some fish in the beard right now so
tonight's tonight's a big night because
you know Triple H was just talking about
when he came over and took over
developmental which literally used to be
developmental it used to be a place
where they would get people and train
them how to be WWE Superstars how to go
on WWE TV and perform in this way and
when you took it over it you branded it
NXT and you started to build this brand
which started to attract eyes of not
people just going like oh I'm just
curious about what's coming next but no
I just want to watch NXT you of some of
the best athletes in the
world and you've brought it so far to a
point like WWE Network specials a weekly
television show on the network to
tonight which is the first time that NXT
is going live on USA for two hours in
primetime in your weekly slot so what is
today like for you I mean this this has
to be an insane it is yeah
and and it's just been a crazy ride of
of doing this in thinking it's gonna get
to a certain point and then it just
keeps growing and growing and growing
and you're you're riding along with it
but it's been a methodical growth
pattern and getting where we are now
where I think you know the term
developmental for me everybody in this
business until the day you're out of it
is developmental in some way you're
gonna learn about this until because
because crowds change the way people
want to watch change so all that stuff
shifts so you're constantly learning in
this because it's a live product mm-hmm
so it's gonna constantly change you're
not just making a static television show
that you record and put out and put a
laugh track on it or something so so
there's always gonna be that but I think
today really marks the point for me
anyways where NXT hits the same sort of
plain as Raw and SmackDown is it on the
same level at the exact moment no is it
you know to the same level of knowledge
or anything else no but this is the
moment in time where there are now three
distinct brands raw Smackdown NXT I
believe talent can go from one to the
other back and forth and and you know
create longevity to their careers where
you know if you're in one place for 10
years that's a long time people see me
doing mmm the same thing over and over
again for 10 years the ability to go
from one to the other and work with
different people and do different things
reinvent yourself all that stuff it just
creates longevity for careers and then
as that grows and you see NXT UK yeah we
expand globally now we have a
Performance Centre in London as that
expands globally you'll see more of
those so you'll see territories
lack of a better term around the globe
where people can go and continue to grow
their careers and make it longer so that
they have that they can spend their
entire arc here and have it be
meaningful and in a professional way not
running out there trying to hope the guy
pays you and if I get hurt now what you
know and do you think as far as this has
expanded past developmental that it's
big of a brand instead of a department
right yes so do you think that you will
still have the same level of autonomy
that you've had over it as big as this
thing gets or is Vince the type of
person that goes like look I trust you
but you're now sending this out to
millions of people I need to have my
hands on this ya know it's an
interesting question so you know the one
thing that people don't give credit for
- Vince is that all everything in this
company eventually is because of him
right like at this point Lee if he
doesn't want to do it isn't happening if
he doesn't see the value in it it isn't
happening and I get that people could
look at it and go yeah but NXT was over
here was a network saying no big deal
but he saw the growth he saw everything
happening he saw the alternative nature
of it different than what yo Ron
Smackdown R he understands that
difference and why one works and why the
other one doesn't and what needs to be
put out there for the masses and for the
general population also what needs to be
put out there for more passionate you
know more deeper level of engagement
fans NXT is something different it isn't
necessarily what Ron Smackdown would be
because those are the general
entertainment show so is his ability to
separate and see the two was huge right
now there is no he knows what makes it
successful he's like just go make this
successful and trust me I did something
that was tragically wrong he would be
like what are you doing right you know
so he'll put his hands on if need be but
as long as it's still successful just
keep doing yeah and and when I say that
that's that's no different than anything
else in the company everything else was
running in the company but when you're
at his level with all the stuff this
company has going on his view is that a
hundred thousand feet or higher and he's
just looking at things and if you see
something wrong he goes hey I don't I
think this is maybe the wrong direction
for us as a company
um that's been since the beginning of
NXT if he sees something that he doesn't
like yeah he's gonna make a comment
about it and you either defend it or
change it right and that's the way it's
always been but the but the success of
this has led him to believe it's in the
right direction and he's it that it's
just going you know what I mean it's
just going and and with all the stuff we
have going on it you just look at it
just this week alone 7 hours of live
content that's if you don't count 205 on
the network right so if you do that's 8
hours of content just this week and then
there's a pay-per-view on Sunday that's
gonna be every week going forward yeah
yeah yeah well yeah that's the one thing
like I'm thinking to myself the other
day I'm like man I've been in Orlando a
bunch I better get used to that yeah all
the sudden it escalated rapidly you know
yeah well Tripoli unlike Sam I have
total faith in your ability to run NXT I
don't think you're apologize for Samsung
did imply me you need help
the last time I saw ru and I saw you and
Stephanie I think it was backstage at
Black Sabbath yeah I think that's the
last time I saw you what's the last
concert you went to last concert I went
to was a few weeks ago I went to go see
ZZ Top in in New Hampshire we have a
place up in New Hampshire and we Billy's
been a fan and dusty have been fans for
forever they've been coming I mean I've
known them since probably 95 coming to
events and they're huge fans great beers
for ya great pop the beers pop the
comments a little bit a shot but huge
fans been friends of ours for a long
period of time so we just went to go see
them was a spectacular concert the 50th
anniversary which it's a funny thing you
know like Billy made a comment in the
show like 50 years same three guys Wow
same three chords I've never actually
one band I'd like to see live in there
and they were they were phenomenal yeah
they were really really good would you
like to collaborate with Lemmy I mean
not just know him you know what I mean
but you actually collaborated on music
for yourself with Lemmy it was
awesome you know I didn't when when we
first did the first the game track that
was written by Jim Johnson and the
Deborah w/e i didn't know lamb at all so
when they did it and it was a long
process of me getting to the point where
they were like let's get Motorhead to do
this I mean obviously you're a fan yeah
forever yeah yeah that was the sound I
wanted the problem was they kept
recording this this version of the song
and I hated it and I kept they would say
what do you want it to sound like and I
would say Motorhead much more like
Motorhead that that raw guttural sound
like that you know aggressive and and
finally they were like well just get
Motorhead to do it because I didn't know
that was an option and they agreed to do
it and then when you know didn't know
anything about it they sent me a video
of me and pictures and stuff music okay
I can make that guy he rewrote the song
did the stuff and recorded it it wasn't
until later we met in a couple times and
you know cordial and everything and then
I did a track with them on an album
called hammered for them there's a track
called serial killer - spoken word piece
LEM called me and was like hey if we
bring you out to LA would you do this
track with me I think our voices that
sound cool synced up together mm-hmm and
so I was like yeah come and do our side
well yeah so it was just a spoken word
piece but I sat in the studio with them
for two days while they were making that
album and LEM had already finished all
his bass tracks so he was just there and
I was just waiting to do my stuff while
everybody else you know Phil was Mickey
wasn't even there Phil was doing his
guitar stuff
LEM and I just sat on a couch in this
living room for like two straight days I
just became really good friends like you
just like it's hard for me to explain
the relationship because he was
obviously a lot older and in a different
place but we would have this we have
this relationship just where like he'd
call me out of the blue and it was like
we'd been on the phone five minutes ago
but I hadn't talked to him in three
months
isn't it interesting to what he was into
he really a big world war two buff like
all the stuff you'd never a crazy crazy
historian where
or two he was incredibly smart you know
his lyrics I think when you look at his
lyrics if you read into the lyrics some
of them are incredibly smart some other
incredibly tongue-in-cheek like yeah he
just made fun music and he made music he
liked and but he he was very with LEM
what you saw was what he was there was
no he didn't just like that because that
was how you were supposed to look as a
rock star that's just how we wanted to
dress and he acted a certain way and the
things he said he had a just a very
simplistic way of looking at the world
and life and he had been through
injuries I remember the first thing that
he said to me that really led us into
having a conversation away from because
when we spoke we hardly ever talked
about wrestling but away from music or
anything else he just said hey when you
had to your injury with your leg he said
did you think your career was over how
did you deal with that because men when
they told me I was diabetic I thought I
was done and man that really got in my
head and that started the conversation
between the two of us in a different
route he would come to like the Staples
Center
we'd be gonna you know we're gonna have
TV there on a vent there I'd get a call
from Todd or he'd leave me a message LEM
would and say uh sorry you're at Staples
gonna stop by I'd get message that he
was there he'd pull his limo he'd have
our production people wait he wasn't
like a huge fan so he would sit in the
car and then before my match would come
he'd they'd bring him out he'd sit in
the arena I'd put him over when I went
to the ring I'd have my match I didn't
usually lose I'd go over to him he'd go
you're perfect for Motorhead you never
win and then he'd say you know I'll be
in the car and I would get done the show
I'd go shower and stuff two hours later
whatever I'd come out he'd limo still be
underneath he'd just be sitting in a
limo
most times just him I'd go knock on the
door I'd get in the car we'd sit in the
car sometimes me sometimes regal
sometimes other people but mostly me and
him and we just sit for a couple hours
and just that's awesome get in the car
and chat and talk about life and he did
that in London he'd show up in London or
you know if we were in town a couple
times we'd stop by the rainbow I'd you
know and me and I would just sit and eat
sometime one time he hadn't closed it
down just
he and I could just sit in there and
just talk that life stuff has to blow
your mind like you have this friendship
with Lemmy and then I was watching your
like WrestleMania diary and you and
Stephanie are hanging out in Rick
Rubin's Oh my house it's like this
creative genius and you're just like
yeah here's my process here's how I hang
out yeah and then like ten minutes later
we're at Rick Rubin's house and he's
like hey come in the back I got this
this kid's gonna come and perform for me
today which you know if you're the kid
playing is mind blowing right yeah where
we walk in the back and he's got Bob
Dylan's old tour bus that he's had
refurbished into like a recording studio
and like it the whole thing is just
trippy and if you've ever met Rick like
he's trippy yeah yeah just surreal
there's some things like that I'm not a
big like my like a big like starstruck
I've never been that way like to me
people are people and then you meet them
and they're either cool or they're not
doesn't matter what they do and but yeah
there's you know it's a funny thing for
me growing up there was only certain
people that I really looked at and
thought like oh man that guy's something
cool like Arnold or something and then
later I did a lot of stuff with him and
and got to be friends with him and just
different people that have come in and
out and and of my life and been
extraordinarily lucky in that sense of
just being a lot around a lot of really
cool people and to me moments in time
like when you get to sit with Rick Rubin
even just sit in a room with him for a
couple hours you learned so much about
not not the music but just perceptions
of life and how he thinks of things like
that perspective of stuff I learned so
many things from LEM without him ever
probably thinking he was ever teaching
me anything I guess in a way like but
just just being around it makes you
think of things differently and it's
just a really cool process just the
stuff Rick Rubin did with with Johnny
Cash was really great do you ever see
the video you probably have for God's
gonna cut you down it's this black and
white video and I think they made it
after Johnny Cash died where they have
all these interesting people and they
have one of the guys from ZZ Top making
these weird cameos yes yeah I mean that
stuff is crazy and that Johnny Cash
things so you talked about collaborating
with Lemmy yeah what
when when LEM was really sick he got
really sick and then probably a year or
two before he passed but then he kind of
made it come back and into use wrestling
terms kicked out way to come back and
then I did well for a while and before
he passed and so during that time when
he was really sick I saw him in LA and
we talked to him about doing some covers
and that the Rick Rubin Johnny Cash
stuff was an inspiration to me because I
loved the voice and the things that they
did that were different so much yeah
that uh we sat in the back of the
Staples Center and started talking about
hey what a man what if you did some
covers and you know we did this project
together and and we'll promote it and
you know and he was really into it and
we had a deal created with the record
label and we started putting together a
list of tracks and I'll never forget it
because Neil aoi our music guy was in
the room and at first was like you know
what do you mean like what do you like
what kind of music and I'm like you know
LEM some outside-the-box stuff right
like stuff that people would never think
you would do but yet your voice is so
iconic that in those moments it's
incredibly powerful and I named off a
couple of things and then Neil goes you
know maybe even a rap track and lemmy's
eyes bugged out of his head and he was
like covers cover of shout it out loud
or a great one of breaking the law
let me did great cover yeah really good
so so interesting story and now this'll
sound like I'm touching and I'm not
trying to take credit for anything here
but I'm just other that's cuz it's a fun
story is so we're sitting in that room
and one of the tracks I mentioned is
sympathy for the devil I said and he was
like not a big stones like he's a big
Beatles guy wasn't a big stones guy and
I I'm like man to me that song with your
voice on it LEM like you're the devil
right like that your voice like that's
that man that is I don't know so I
talked I talked him into it and so first
one he does
as that cover for this album that we
were going to do that was all cover
tracks and he sends me a cut of it like
I don't know they they go in and they
recorded a couple weeks later and Todd
his managers sending us feedback like
dude this thing is incredible everybody
in the studio is freaking out about how
good it is LEM sends it over to me
and he's like he leaves an entire verse
of the song out and I call him up and
I'm like Clem this sounds incredible but
like you got to do the whole song man
like the song is too long it's not the
song if you don't know the song is you
got to do the whole thing and you know
he's like I'll think about it and then
Todd called and finally he said he said
because you want him to do a he'll he'll
agree to do it so they did it they
finished it and then like everybody was
freaking out and they've used that thing
for commercials you know all that stuff
and the other song that we had on the
list was Bowie's heroes uh would have
been amazing know he did it
Diddy it's all you heard that you know
not Bowie's heroes oh my god so if when
when we suggested it we're in the room
and I was like David Bowie like heroes
you doing that so he's like I am NOT
singing about dolphins but the song
itself so cool and I could picture Phil
doing it with the guitar you know listen
to it it's awesome lemon rewrote the
lyrics and they did the track they were
supposed to do a whole bunch of them and
you know towards the end he knew right
he didn't know until he came back and
they told him you know he went in
because it was breaking down bad and
that's when they look you know they did
the scan and said dude you got brain
cancer like you're done like but get
shocked that you're here and which
shocking that he found here probably for
the like but he knew you know that that
run on the end and like he did those
tracks but then they ended up putting
I'm out on like sympathy he put out on
bad magic I think
last album they did they did the
undercover album they did I think that's
where they put heroes and stuff but tell
that to the last one of the last times I
saw him we did an interview with him I
asked him about doing an interview I
said you know I didn't really say it in
this manner but I could tell well I
could tell when I was talking to him he
was checking out you know like not not
checking out in like he was off checking
out in like yeah I'm at the end dude
well yeah you know when when I wouldn't
we would leave it was might be last time
yeah so I asked him about doing an
interview and he said yeah and at that
time he wasn't doing anything and I
brought Corey graves with me cuz Corey
graves a fan I needed like somebody to
ask questions cuz LEM and I had go off
on this tangent and never talked about
anything
interesting except something to he and I
and we went to the rainbow was closed
they just put me Cory and and Lemmy
we've never put it out yet but it's one
of the last interviews that he's ever
how oh you should put that out yeah I
can't wait we're he that yeah it's
something that we're talking about doing
in this in this coming year and we've
just kind of been waiting for the right
time but it's one of the last interviews
that he did and it's I mean it's amazing
but in even at that meeting so his
manager Todd was there and for like 20
minutes leaving as we're walking out he
is blistering Todd about the fact that
they couldn't get all these covers on
the album and Todd is like lemon there's
only so much space on a vinyl like I
can't put more stuff on there I gotta
take a song off if you want to put
another song on and lemons I don't care
you're so full of crap all these songs
on that album and it's [ __ ] and he
was so mad at Todd
we just talked about it the other day
because they just sent me some stuff and
I was talking to Todd and he was a con
member how mad he was at me for those
covers not being on Doug the covers in
it was so from a collaborative process
it was so like it's amazing fun doing
stuff with him and kind of getting I
don't know getting his take on it and
getting him outside of the box of doing
stuff it was a lot of fun
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]